math is sometimes a real tease
it seduces us with the beauty of
reasoning geometrically in two and three
dimensions
where there's this really nice back and
forth between pairs or triplets of
numbers
and spatial stuff that our visual cortex
is good at processing
for example if you think about a circle
with radius 1
centered at the origin you are in effect
conceptualizing
every possible pair of numbers x and y
that satisfy a certain numerical
property
that x squared plus y squared is one
and the usefulness here is that a lot of
facts that look opaque
in a purely analytic context become
quite clear geometrically
and vice versa honestly this channel has
been the direct beneficiary
of this back and forth since it offers
such a rich library of that special
category of cleverness that involves
connecting two
seemingly disparate ideas and i don't
just mean the general back and forth
between pairs or triplets of numbers and
spatial reasoning
i mean this specific one between sums of
squares and circles and spheres
it's at the heart of the video i made
showing how pi is connected to number
theory and primes
and the one showing how to visualize all
possible pythagorean triples
it also underlies the video on the
borsuk ulam theorem being used to solve
what was basically a counting puzzle by
using topological facts about spheres
there is no doubt that the ability to
frame analytic facts
geometrically is very useful for math
but it's all a tease
because when you start asking questions
about quadruplets or quintuplets
or 100 tuples of numbers it's
frustrating
the constraints on our physical space
seem to have constrained our intuitions
about geometry and we lose this back and
forth
i mean it is completely reasonable to
imagine that there are problems out
there that would have clever and
illuminating
solutions if only we knew how to
conceptualize
say lists of ten numbers as individual
points in some space
for mathematicians or computer
scientists or physicists
problems that are framed in terms of
lists of numbers lists of more than
three numbers
are a regular part of the job and the
standard approach to actually
doing math in higher dimensions is to
use two and three dimensions for
analogy but to fundamentally reason
about things just
analytically somewhat analogous to a
pilot relying primarily on instruments
and not sight
while flying through the clouds now what
i want to offer here is a hybrid
between the purely geometric and the
purely analytic views
a method for making the analytic
reasoning a little more visual
in a way that generalizes to arbitrarily
high dimensions
and to drive home the value of a tactic
like this i want to share with you a
very famous example
where analogies with two and three
dimensions cannot help
because of something extremely
counter-intuitive that only happens in
higher dimensions
the hope though is that what i show you
here helps to make that phenomenon
more intuitive the focus throughout will
be on higher dimensional spheres
for example when we talk about a
four-dimensional sphere
say with radius one centered at the
origin what that actually
is is the set of all quadruplets of
numbers
x y z w where the sum of the squares of
these numbers
is one what i have pictured here now is
multiple three dimensional slices of a
4d sphere
projected back into three dimensions but
it's confusing
and even if you do wrap your head around
it it just pushes the question back to
how you would think about a five or a
six or a seven dimensional sphere
and more importantly squinting your eyes
to understand a projection like this
is not very reflective of what doing
math with a 4d sphere
actually entails instead the basic idea
here will be to get very literal about
it
and to think about four separate numbers
i like to picture four vertical number
lines
with sliders to represent each number
each configuration of these sliders
is a point in 4d space a quadruplet of
numbers
and what it means to be on a 4d unit
sphere
centered at the origin is that the sum
of the squares of these four values
is one
our goal is to understand which
movements of these sliders
correspond to movements on the sphere
to do that it helps if we knock things
down to two dimensions where we can
actually see the circle
so ask yourself what's a nice way to
think about this relation
that x squared plus y squared is one
well i like to think of the value of x
squared as the real estate belonging to
x
and likewise the value of y squared is
the real estate belonging to y
and that they have a total of one unit
of real estate to share between them
so moving around on the circle
corresponds to a constant exchange
of real estate between the two variables
part of the reason i choose this term is
that it lets us make a very useful
analogy
that real estate is cheap near zero and
more expensive
away from zero to see this consider
starting off in a position where
x equals 1 and y is 0 meaning x has
all of the real estate to itself which
in our usual geometric picture means
we're on the rightmost point of the
circle
if you move x down just a bit to 0.9
the value of x squared changes to 0.81
so it has in effect given up 0.19
units of real estate but for y squared
to increase
by that same amount y has to move an
entire
0.44 units away from zero more than
four times the amount that x moved in
other words
x changed a little to give up expensive
real estate so that y could move a lot
and gain the same value of cheap real
estate in terms of the usual circle
drawing
this corresponds to the steep slope near
the right side
a small nudge in x allows for a very big
change to y
moving forward let's add some tick marks
to these lines to indicate what 0.05
units of real estate looks like at each
point that is
how much would x have to change so that
the value of x squared
changes by 0.05 as you walk around the
circle
the trade-off in value between x squared
and y squared
gives this piston-looking dance motion
where the sliders are moving more slowly
away from zero
because real estate is more expensive in
those regions there are just
more tick marks to cover per unit
distance
also a nice side effect of the term real
estate is that it aligns naturally with
the fact that it comes in units of
distance squared
so the square root of the total real
estate among all coordinates
gives us the distance from the origin
for a unit sphere in three dimensions
the set of all triplets x y z where the
sum of their squares is one
all we have to do is add a third slider
for z
but these three sliders still only have
the one unit of real estate to share
between them
to get a feel for this imagine holding x
in place at 0.5
where it occupies 0.25 units of real
estate
what this means is that y and z can move
around in the same piston-dense motion
we saw before
as they trade off the remaining 0.75
units of real estate in terms of our
typical way of visualizing a sphere
this corresponds to slicing the sphere
along the plane where
x is 0.5 and looking at the circle
formed by
all of the choices for y and z on that
sphere
as you increase the value of x the
amount of real estate left over for y
and z
is smaller and this more constrained
piston dance is what it feels like
for the circular slice to be smaller
eventually
once x reaches the value 1 there's no
real estate left over
so you reach this singularity point
where y and z are both forced to be zero
the feeling here is a bit like being a
bug on the surface of the sphere
you are unable to see the whole sphere
all at once
instead you're just sitting on a single
point and you have some sense for what
local movements are allowed
in four dimensions and higher we lose
the crutch of the global view that a
spatial visual offers
but the fundamental rules of this real
estate exchange
remain the same if you fix one slider in
place
and watch the other three trade off this
is basically what it means to take a
slice
of the 4d sphere to get a small 3d
sphere
in much the same way that fixing one of
the sliders for the three-dimensional
case gave us a circular slice
when the remaining two were free to vary
now watching these sliders move about
and thinking about the real estate
exchange
is pretty fun but it runs the risk of
being aimless unless we have an actual
high dimensional puzzle to sink our
teeth into so let's
set aside the sliders for just a moment
and bring in a very classic example
of something that seems reasonable and
even dull
in two and three dimensions but which is
totally out of whack in higher
dimensions
to start take a 2 by 2 box centered at
the origin
its corners are on the vertices 1 1 1
negative 1
negative 1 1 and negative 1 negative 1.
draw four circles each with radius one
centered at these four vertices so each
one is tangent to two of its neighbors
now i want you to think of the circle
centered at the origin which is just
large enough to be touching
those corner circles tangent to each one
of them
what we want to do for this setup and
for its analogies in higher dimensions
is find the radius of that inner circle
here in two dimensions we can use the
pythagorean theorem to see that the
distance from the origin
to the corner of the box is the square
root of 2 which is around 1.414
then you can subtract off this portion
here the radius of the corner circle
which by definition is 1 and that means
the radius of the inner circle
is square root of 2 minus 1 or about
0.414 no surprises here that seems
pretty reasonable
now do something analogous in three
dimensions draw a two by two by two
cube whose corners have vertices one one
one
one one negative one on and on and on
and then we're gonna take eight
different spheres each of which has a
radius one
and center them on these vertices so
that each one
is tangent to three of its neighbors
now again think about the sphere
centered at the origin
which is just large enough to be barely
touching those eight corner spheres
as before we can start by thinking about
the distance from the origin
to the corner of the box say the corner
at one one one
by the way i guess i still haven't yet
explicitly said that the way distances
work in higher dimensions
is always to add up the squares of the
components in each direction
and take the square root if you've never
seen why this follows from the
pythagorean theorem
just in the two-dimensional case it's
actually a really fun puzzle to think
about
and i've left the relevant image up on
the screen for any of you who want to
pause and ponder on it
anyway in our case the distance between
the origin and the corner 1 1
1 is the square root of 1 squared plus 1
squared plus 1 squared or square root of
3
which is about 1.73 so the radius of
that inner sphere
is going to be this quantity minus the
radius of a corner sphere
which by definition is 1. and again
0.73 seems like a reasonable radius
for that inner sphere but what happens
to that inner radius as you
increase dimensions obviously the reason
i bring this up
is that something surprising will happen
and some of you might see where this is
going
but i actually don't want it to feel
like a surprise
as fun as it is to wow people with
counter-intuitive facts and math
the goal here is genuine understanding
not shock
for higher dimensions we'll be using
sliders to get a gut feel for what's
going on
but since it's kind of a different way
of viewing things it helps to get a
running start by looking back
at how to analyze the two and three
dimensional cases in the context of
sliders
first things first how do you think
about a circle centered at a corner
like one negative one well previously
for
a circle centered at the origin the
amount of real estate belonging to both
x and y was dependent on their distance
from the number zero
and it's the same basic idea here as you
move around the center
it's just that the real estate might be
dependent on the distance between each
coordinate and some other number
so for this circle centered at one
negative one
the amount of real estate belonging to x
is the square
of its distance from one likewise the
real estate belonging to y
is the square of its distance from
negative one
other than that the look and feel with
this piston dance trade-off is
completely the same for simplicity we'll
only focus on one of these circles the
one centered at one one
now ask yourself what does it mean to
find a circle centered at the origin
large enough to be tangent to this guy
when we're thinking just in terms of
sliders
well notice how this point of tangency
happens when the x and y coordinates are
both the same
or phrase differently at the point of
this corner circle
closest to the origin the real estate is
shared evenly
between x and y this will be important
for later so let's really dig in and
think about why it's true
imagine perturbing that point slightly
maybe moving x
a little closer to zero which means y
would have to move a little away from
zero the change in x
would have to be a little smaller than
the change in y since the real estate it
gains by moving farther away from one
is more expensive than the real estate
that y loses
by getting closer to one but from the
perspective of the origin point
0 0 that tradeoff is reversed the
resulting change to x squared
is smaller than the resulting change to
y squared
since when real estate is measured with
respect to 0
0 that move of y towards 1
is the more expensive one what this
means is that any slight perturbation
away from this point where real estate
is shared evenly
results in an increasing distance from
the origin
the reason we care is that this point is
tangent to the inner circle
so we can also think about it as being a
point of the inner circle
and this will be very useful for higher
dimensions it gives us a reference point
to understanding the radius of that
inner
circle specifically you can ask how much
real estate is shared between x and y
at this point when real estate
measurements are done with respect to
the origin
zero zero for example down here in two
dimensions
both x and y dip below 0.5
in this configuration so the total value
x squared plus y
squared is going to be less than 0.5
squared
plus 0.5 squared comparing to this
halfway point is really going to come in
handy for wrapping our mind around what
happens in higher dimensions
taking things one step at a time let's
bump it up to 3 dimensions
consider the corner sphere with radius 1
centered at one one one
the point on that sphere that's closest
to the origin
corresponds to the configuration of
sliders where x y and z
are all reaching down towards zero and
equal to each other
again they all have to go a little
beyond that halfway point
because the position 0.5 only accounts
for 0.5 squared
or 0.25 units of real estate
so with all three coordinates getting a
third of a unit of real estate
they need to be farther out and again
since this is a point where the corner
sphere is tangent to the inner sphere
it's also a point of the inner sphere so
with reference to the origin
0 0 0 think about the amount of real
estate
shared between x y and z in this
position
corresponding to the tangent point it's
definitely less than 0.75
since all three of these are smaller
than 0.5 so
each one has less than 0.25 units of
real estate
and again we sit back and feel
comfortable with this result right
the inner sphere is smaller than the
corner spheres
but things get interesting when we move
up into four dimensions
our two by two by two by two box is
going to have sixteen vertices
at one one one one one one negative one
and so on with all possible binary
combinations of one
and negative one what this means is that
there are 16 unit spheres
centered at these corners each one
tangent to four of its neighbors
as before we'll just be focusing on one
of them the one centered at one one one
one
the point of the sphere closest to the
origin corresponds to the configuration
of sliders
where all four coordinates reach exactly
halfway
between one and zero and that's because
when one of the coordinates is 0.5 units
away from 1
it has 0.25 units of real estate
with respect to the point 1. we do the
same trick as before
thinking of this now as a point of the
inner sphere and measuring things with
respect to the origin
but you can already see what's cool
about four dimensions
as you switch to thinking of real estate
with respect to zero zero zero zero
it's still the case that each of these
four coordinates
has 0.25 units of real estate making for
a total of one shared between the four
coordinates
in other words that inner sphere is
precisely the same size
as the corner spheres this matches with
what you see numerically by the way
where you can compute the distance
between the origin and the corner
one one one one is the square root of
four and then when you subtract off the
radius of one of the corner spheres
what you get is one but there's
something much more satisfying about
seeing it rather than just computing it
in particular here's a cool aspect of
the fact that that inner sphere has
radius one
move things around so that all of the
real estate goes to the coordinate
x and you'll end up at the point one
zero zero
zero this point is actually touching the
two by two by two by two
box and when you're stuck thinking in
the two or three dimensional cases
this fact that the inner sphere has
radius one
the same size as the corner spheres and
that it touches the box
well it just seems too big but it's
important to realize
this is fundamentally a four-dimensional
phenomenon and you just can't cram it
down
into smaller dimensions but things get
weirder
let's knock it up to five dimensions in
this case we have quite a few corner
spheres 32 in total
but again for simplicity we'll only be
thinking about the one centered at 1 1 1
1 think about the point of this sphere
closest to the origin
where all five coordinates are equally
splitting the one unit of shared real
estate
this time each coordinate is a little
higher than 0.5
if they reach down to 0.5 each one would
have 0.25
units of real estate giving a total of
1.25
which is too much but the tables are
turned when you view this as a point
on the inner sphere because with respect
to the origin
this configuration has much more than
one unit of real estate
not only is every coordinate more than
.5 units away from zero
but the larger number of dimensions
means that there's more total real
estate when you add it all up
specifically you can compute that the
radius of that inner sphere
is about 1.24 the intuitive feel for
what that means
is that the sliders can roam over more
territory
than what just a single unit of real
estate would allow
one fun way to see what this means is to
adjust everything so that all of the
real estate goes to just one coordinate
because this coordinate can reach beyond
one what you are seeing
is that this five dimensional inner
sphere actually pokes
outside the box
but to really get a feel for how strange
things become as a last example i want
to jump up into 10 dimensions
remember all this means is that points
have 10 coordinates
for a sphere with radius 1 a single unit
of real estate must be shared among
all 10 of those coordinates as always
the point of this cornersphere closest
to the origin
is the one where all 10 coordinates
split the real estate evenly
and here you can really see just how far
away this feels from the origin
or phrased differently that inner sphere
is allowed to have
a very large amount of real estate in
fact
you can compute that the radius of the
inner sphere is about 2.16
and viewed from this perspective where
you have 10 full dimensions to share
that real estate
doesn't it actually feel somewhat
reasonable that the inner sphere
should have a radius more than twice as
big as all those corner spheres
to get a sense for just how big this
inner sphere is
look back in two dimensions and imagine
a four by four box
bounding all four circles from the
outside
or go to three dimensions and imagine a
four by four by four box
bounding all of those corner spheres
from the outside
way up here in ten dimensions that
quote-unquote
inner sphere is actually large enough to
poke outside of that outer bounding box
since it has a diameter bigger than four
i know that seems crazy but you have to
realize that the face of the box
is always two units away from the origin
no matter how high the dimension is
and fundamentally it's because it only
involves moving along a single axis
but the point one one one one one one
one one which determines the inner
sphere's radius
is actually really far away from the
center all the way up here in 10
dimensions
and it's because all 10 of those
dimensions add
a full unit of real estate for that
point
and of course as you keep upping the
dimensions that inner sphere just keeps
growing without bound
not only is it poking outside of these
boxes but the proportion of the inner
sphere
lying inside the box decreases
exponentially towards zero
as the dimension keeps increasing
so taking a step back one of the things
i like about using this slider method
for teaching
is that when i shared it with a few
friends the way they started to talk
about higher dimensions
became a little less metaphysical and
started to sound more like how you would
hear a mathematician talk about the
topic
rather than skeptically asking whether
or not 10 dimensional space is a real
thing
recognizing that it's exactly as real as
numbers are
people would actually probe at what
other properties high dimensional
spheres have
and what other shapes feel like in terms
of sliders
this box situation is just one in a
number of things that feel very crazy
about higher dimensional spheres and
it's really fun to think about these
others
in the context of sliders and real
estate it's obviously limited
i mean you're a bug on the surface of
these objects only getting a feel for
one point at a time
and for the rules of movement also
geometry can be quite nice when it's
coordinate free and this is the opposite
of that
but it does give a foothold into
thinking about high dimensional shapes
a little more concretely
now you could say that viewing things
with sliders is
no different from thinking about things
purely analytically
i mean it's honestly little more than
representing each coordinate
literally it's kind of the most obvious
thing you might do
but this small move makes it much more
possible to play
with the thought of a high dimensional
point and even little things
like thinking about the squares of
coordinates as real estate can shed
light on some seemingly strange
aspects of high dimensions like just how
far away the corner of a box is from its
center
if anything the fact that it's such a
direct representation of a purely
analytic description
is exactly what makes it such a faithful
reflection of what genuinely doing math
and higher dimensions entails
we're still flying in the clouds
trusting the instruments of analytic
reasoning
but this is a redesign of those
instruments one which better takes
advantage of the fact that such a large
portion of our brains goes towards image
processing
i mean just because you can't visualize
something
doesn't mean you can't still think about
it visually
you